من شمال ادلب نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوريه منير مصطفى منير امام التحديات
التي باتت معروفه والتي تواجه فرق الانقاذ
ومتطوعي الدفاع المدني هلا اخبرتنا عن كيف
يتعامل هؤلاء مع تلك التحديات وما هي
المصاعب التي يواجهونها وكيف تجري عمليات
الانقاذ في شمال السوري
في الحقيقه المصاعب كما ذكرت هي مصاعب
كبيره بسبب عدم وصول المساعدات من اي دوله
رغم المناشدات التي اطلقها الدفاع المدني
منذ الساعات الاولى من وقوع هذه الكارثه
طريقه التعامل التي اتخذها فريق الفوز
البيضاء هو اول اول شيء قام بموضوع
استنفار كافه الكوادر وكافه الاليات وكافه
العاملين بشكل كامل هم متواجدون في مناطق
العمل نحن نتكلم عن 2800 متطوع هم موجودين
على ارض الواقع موجودين
بمناطق العمليات ايضا الامر الاخر هو
الاستعانه صراحه بالقدرات المحليه الاليات
المدنيه المتوفره في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
فهناك استعانه بكثير من هذه الاليات حتى
وضعوها المدنيين بين يديه الدفاع المدني
من اجل استخدامها في انتشار الع ايضا هناك
مجموعه من المتطوعين عمل الدفاع المدني
بالفتره الماضيه قبل وقوع هذه الكارثه على
تدريب هؤلاء المتطوعين حتى يكونوا متطوعين
في مثل هذه الكوارث تم استدعاء هؤلاء
المتطوعين وهم موجودون كرديف لفريق الخواز
البيضاء ويصل تعدادهم حتى الالف شخص هم
موجودون كرديف البيضاء على الارض يقومون
بمسانده فرق الدفاع المدني ولكن يعني حتى
نكون واضحين وصريحين كل هذه الاجراءات
المتخذه من قبل فريق البيضاء هي اجراءات
غير كافيه الكارثه ترقى الى مستوى ان
تتدخل بها دول على المستويات فهذه
الامكانات المتوفره بين يديك فريق القوه
البيضاء وبين يدي المدنيين الذين يؤازرون
الخوذ البيضاء في العمل على الارض هي غير
كافيه وكما تعلم الساعات الاولى من وقوع
الكارثه هي ساعات جدا مهمه نحن نتكلم عن
ساعه طبعا اول 72 ساعه هي جدا مهمه بانقاذ
حياه وسحب عالق وهو على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاذ عندما نتجاوز 72 ساعه يكون احتمال
انتشال احياء من تحت الانقاب يكون اقل
بكثير فنحن نصارع الزمن بشكل فعلي نصارى
الزمن بشكل واقعي على الارض من اجل يعني
انتشار كافه الاحياء العالقين عندما تمديد
اليه ايصال المساعدات عبر معبر باب الهوى
كان هناك تقديرات بانه المده لن تكفي
لايصال المساعدات في ذاك الوقت نتحدث عن
ان الوضع الطبيعي لحالات النزوح واللاجئين
واحتياجاتهم وفصل الشتاء وما الى ذلك الان
المعبر اغلق بالامس في امس الحاجه لادخال
المساعدات ما تفسير ما جرى وهل هناك تواصل
مع المنظمات المعنيه بخصوص ادخال
المساعدات
هلا هلا في الحقيقه يعني يحزن القول ان
الحاله الطبيعيه هي دخول المساعدات الى
المجتمع في شمال غربي سوري شمال غربي
سوريا صراحه هذه ليست حاله طبيعيه هذه
حاله ماساويه كانت سابقا وقوع الزلزال هي
حاله ماساويه اكثر بكثير صراحه هذا ما
يحصل اغلاق المعابر طبعا
المبررات التي تقدم من الجانب التركي هي
الكارثه التي وقعت ايضا في جنوب وهي منطقه
التي سوف تمر منها المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا فهذه هي المبررات ولكن صراحه نحن
نناشد الدول ان يكون هناك فتح معابر
اضافيه يعني الحدود طويله الحدود من منطقه
جرابلس حتى منطقه اللاذقيه هي حدود مئات
الكيلومترات ممتده حدود بين سوريا وتركيا
قد يكون الوصول الى المعابر الرسميه معبر
باب الهوى معبر باب السلامه المعابر
الرسميه الموجوده بشكل فعلي بالمناطق شمال
غرب سوريا وبين شبه مستحيل في ظل ظروف
الظروف التي تمر بها الدوله التركيه نسال
الله يعني السلام للجميع ولكن هذه الحدود
الطويله قد نستطيع ان نفتح ثغرات فيها
نخلق يعني يعني اداره معبر سريعه لهذه
الحاله الانسانيه الطارئه تساعد بوصول
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا
لنفهم اكثر هل هناك من من يعني تبرع
بايصال هذه المساعدات لكن امامه عوائق
لوجستيه
في الحقيقه هناك عده دول يعني تواصلوا مع
الخواز البيضاء وابدوا استعدادهم لايصال
هذه المساعدات ولكن السؤال دائما كيفيه
وصول هذه المساعدات طبعا يوجه هذا السؤال
لفريق البيضاء طبعا نحن في دورنا يعني
نوجه هذه الدول للتواصل مع الجانب التركي
للتواصل معهم على على فتح معبر يعني مستقل
باداره مستقله يكون فقط هو معبر استثنائي
لهذه اللحظات منير يعني نعرف ان
السكان في شمال
سوريا يحتاجون الى كل شيء في هذه الظروف
وفي هذا الطقس العاصف وفي ظروف
وتداعيات الزلزال فضلا عن الظروف السابقه
الناجمه عن الحرب لكن الان كدفاع مدني ما
هو المطلوب الاكثر الحاحا في الوقت الحاضر
ماذا تحتاجون
نعم في الحقيقه نحن نتكلم عن اكثر من 700
يعني بناء مدمر
بانم معنى في نفس الوقت صراحه استنفار
مراكز دفاع مدني واستثمار كامل الاليات
وتوزعها على هذه المناطق بات غير كافي
لتخطيط جميع المواقع والعمل في جميع
المواقع فالحاجه في 72 ساعه الاولى صراحه
هي حاجه لبعض الاليات الثقيله التي تستخدم
لرفع الانقاض ورفع الاسقف من فوق العالقين
نحتاج ايضا الى معدات تقنيه معروفه هي لدى
الدول زودناهم بقوائم من هذه المعدات هي
معدات الرفع والمخدات الهوائيه والمعدات
لسحب العالقين من تحت الانقراض التي
تستخدمها فرق الدفاع الذي
موجود جزء من هذه المعدات عند الدفاع
المدني السوري للخواز البيضاء نحن نستخدم
هذه المعدات ولكنها غير كافيه لا تتناسب
مع حجم الكارثه الموجوده فهذا النداء الذي
وجهناه بعجاله خلال 72 ساعه هذه الاليات
قد تكون او هذه المعدات قد تكون هي احد
اسباب انتشال احد الاشخاص من تحت الانقاض
وهو على قيد الحياه يحزننا كثيرا يعني
رؤيه مشاهد شخص نكون نسمع صوته ونحن نحاول
ان نصل اليه هو عندما نصل اليه نجدها قد
فارق الحياه منذ عشر دقائق او ربع ساعه
فهذا بسبب ضعف المعدات المتواجده بين يدي
باضاءه التدريبات والقدرات الموجوده عنده
المتطوعين الخوذه بيضاء تدريبات عاليه
ترقى الى مستوى دول وانا انا واثق من هذا
الكلام ولكن احيانا الامكانات هي تحول بين
ذلك بيننا وبين ذلك على كل يعني هذا
النداء يفترض ان يكون قد وصل شكرا جزيلا
لك نائب مدير الدفاع المدني سوري منير
مصطفى من شمال